erster Tag Bahnstreik
erstehen wofür haben Sie eigentlich mehr
Verständnis für die Bauern oder für die
Lockführer ich habe für schon für beide
Verständnis dass man demonstriert und
protestiert gegen Dinge die man nicht
richtig findet aber es ist natürlich
auch eine Belastungsprobe für die
Gesellschaft und der weselski der Chef
dieser GDL GDL das ist ja eine besondere
Marke
der reizt ja sozusagen da reizt das
natürlich auch alles aus was man da
ausreizen kann also das mit den
spadengewerkchaften gefällt mir
normalerweise nicht so wenn die so
untereinander streiten hilft das eiglich
den Arbeitnehmern in der Regel nicht und
es hilft auch dem Unternehmen nicht
besonders aber das Unternehmen hat auch
ein ein Beitrag dazu
geleistet indem man dann tantien bezahlt
für den Vorstand so als Belohnung für
die Verspätung im letzten Jahr und so
das ist hat auch nicht zur
Friedensfähigkeit beigetragen insofern
kann man das den nicht übel nehmen aber
man hofft natürlich trotzdem dass man
sich am verandungstisch einig und Zar
möglich B aber die DGB Gewerkschaft hat
ja also es gibt ja die größ Gewerkschaft
bei den
Eisenbahnern die hat ja im Sommer und
Frühsommer auch also
warnstreiksveranstalt und zwar bevor
überhaupt verhandelt wurde also die
spartengewerkschaftenel ist so ein
bisschen so eine ja so eine Hassfigur
für viele aber friedlicher waren die
anderen auch nicht werdi hat den
letzten ja ziemlich häufig doch auch im
im k würel die Seriosität nicht
absprechen wollen ehrlich gesagt worum
geht's denn da Frau was wollen die die
la die wollen wie eben auch wie die
Eisenbahner im im Sommer eben hatten die
auch eine recht übige Gehaltssteigerung
die 550€h 550 € mindestens mehr dann
eben die volle inflationsprämie von 3000
€ zusätzlich und und das ist eigentlich
für die Bahne am schwierigsten sie
wollen eine Arbeitszeitverkürzung
Durchsetzen von 5 von 38 auf 35 Stunden
erstmal und eigentlich perspektivisch
auch die vier Tage Woch das ist schon
recht also in einem Bereich in einem
Bereich wo wir ja irgendwie auch viele
viele zugausfäer haben weil wir zu wenig
Zug Führer haben also insofern es ist
ein ganz schwieriges Paket was mich aber
vor allem ärgert wie schnell hier
gestreigt wird weil das ist eben
eigentlich wir hatten Warnstreiks schon
auch jetzt von wski also von den
lockführern schon im Dezember
schon zweimal und jetzt kommt dann noch
mal gleich ein regulärer Streik und das
ist eigentlich ein Verfahren was man
abkürzen könnte im Endeffekt werden sie
eine deutliche Gehaltssteigerung
natürlich durchsetzen wie das ist
wahrscheinlich mit dem längeren Frist
auch eine Arbeitszeitverkürzung aber
dann sollte man das bitte friedlich
machen und nicht so wie es jetzt mit dem
Streik ist dass Millionen Bürger die
sowieso von der Bahn hochgradig genervt
sind weil sie eben ständig zu spät kommt
oder ausfällt gen äh die Boni die sie
erwähnt haben was eigentlich eine
Unverschämtheit ist und jetzt auch noch
eben diese diese
erneute die zweite Gewerkschaft die eben
auch wieder zum Streik aufruft weil sie
viel Geld haben will das ist für die
Bürger eigentlich nicht zu tolerieren
die am Ende ja auch für die mehr Kosten
aufkommen sollen bevor wir gleich an böt
hen sie sie sagen äh Frau Siems an der
Stelle müsste eigentlich das Streikrecht
mal reformiert werden das geht so nicht
das ist also das Streikrecht es ist ganz
das Streikrecht selber ist mit der mit
dem
Tarif recht selbstverständlich Teil der
Verfassung da bin ich auch nicht der
Meinung dass man es ausbeln sollte nur
ist es über Richterrecht und das wissen
Sie ja Stegner auch die Form erstens mal
wie Warnstreiks heute gemacht werden das
war vor in den 60er Jahren gab es das so
nicht das Warnstreik sind noch am Anfang
von
Verhandlungen die tagelang dauern das
ist eigentlich ja schon ein Streik
gewesen was wir im Dezember gesehen
haben und dann ist es eine sehr
kurzfristige Ankündigungsfrist aber was
man vor allen Dingen machen könnte das
wäre ein ganz minimale Entschärfung
gerade in diesem Bereich der zur
öffentlichen Daseinsvorsorge gehört die
Menschen haben vielfach keine
Alternative sie müssen zur Arbeit sie
müssen pendeln und werden von der Bahn
sozusagen auf den also werden stehen
gelassen weil e nichts geht da könnte
man Schlichtungsverfahren vor vorsetzen
es gibt dazu vor arbeitsrechten
rechtlern Vorschläge in anderen Ländern
wie der Schweiz gilt es ja generell ich
würde das nur auf die Bereiche
beschränken wollen die zur unbedingten
öffentlichen Daseinsvorsorge gehören z.B
auch Energieversorgung und
Wasserversorgung auch da wäre sowas
undenkbar und gerade eben hier ist es
eine
ungleich Behandlung eben weil immer die
Leittragenden die Bürger sind und eben
mit einem sehr kleinen also wenn man
sich überlegt wie viele blckführer es
gibt und wie viel Menschen getroffen
werden von der Wirtschaft gar nicht zu
zu sprechen Herr BTG sie dürfen sofort
aber einsatzpr muss schon sein die die
gewerkschafterseele von SPD stegender
kocht jetzt natürlich in der Tat weil
ich natürlich sagen muss bei allem was
uns ärgern mag daran aber das
Streikrecht ist in der Verfassung und
ich muss ehrlich sagen manche Dinge
werden auch nur über lange Streiks
erkämpft das gilt für die lohnverzahlung
Krankheitsfall das galt für den a
stundenag das kam nicht von alleine
haben die Arbeitgeber nie von alleine
gewährt und es ein Fortschritt D wir
Streikrecht haben ich möchte nicht dass
es eingeschränkt wird ich wünsche mir
auch dass es Verhandlung gibt wünsche
mir auch dass die Arbeitgeberseite sich
in der Frage vernünftiger verhält habe
auch nichts von diesen inner gewerkchaft
die Daseinsvorsorge das Anrecht darauf
dass wir dass
wir Bahn haben die ist wichtig aber
Arbeitnehmerrechte sozusagen die sind
nicht zu stark in Deutschland son ist
eine stärker unseres standords dass wir
sie haben und ich bin dagegen sie
einzuschränken ja aber ich meine die
Spartengewerkschaften haben sie ja auch
mit in der großen Koalition
eingeschränkt also ich meine wir haben
Tarif ein also das heißt man ist da
durchaus reingegangen dass man gesagt
hat künftig können eben in Betrieben nur
eine Gewerkschaft da sein um die Gewerk
um diese Spartengewerkschaften also weil
die Feuerwehrleute beispielsweise hätten
das auch gerne gemacht um das eben
einzuschrken ja aber da haben Sie
eigentlich die Koalitionsfreiheit die
auch in der Verfassung ist dass jeder
sich aussuchen darf in was für einer Art
von von Arbeitnehmervertretung und das
haben sie eingeschrkt nein es ist nicht
so dass das seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
sozusagen immer das gleiche
tarifrechte gibt sondern es gibt
durchaus Einschränkung man hat auch das
den Mindestlohn beispielsweise
gesetzlich geregelt auch da hat man
gesagt eigentlich ist es
tarifangelegenheit aber hier mischen wir
uns
mal nicht
geft ich glaube hier ist
die die Bevölkerung getroffen und es
wird
keineerung wir noch viel mehr getofen
wenn Leute die sehr viel Geld haben den
Laden dicht machen und große Abfindung
kriegen und der börsenkur steigigen die
Leute fliegen raus da wird die
Bevölkerung viel stärker geschädigt ALSA
das ist ganz
and die IG Metal ein Unternehmen
bestreigt dann sind nicht Millionen
Arbeitnehmer betroffen weil sie nicht
zur Arbeit kommen weil sie nicht
nicht ja aber sie haben entschieden dass
bei Spartengewerkschaften eben
reingegangen wird und das künftig eben
erschwert ist also ich finde das sie
sind eben sehr
einseitig hier für dieses Streikrecht
und ich bin eben auf Seiten der Bürger
und auch der Wirtschaft der Güterverkehr
ist ja auch massiv betroffen die eben
sagen dass wir diese Regelung es hat was
von einem
Selbstbedienungsladen die Bahn die Boni
die gezahlt werden man streiten kann
ohne jedes Arbeits
Arbeitsplatzrisiko weil das ein
Staatsbetrieb ist also das ist mir zu
heftig was da an Folgen inzwischen
ertragen werden muss zweimal
Gewerkschaften in einem Jahr zwei
unterschiedliche Gewerk en bei einem
Unternehmen und es es trifft immer die
Bürger das ist nicht zumutbar sie sagen
müssen wir einfach aushalten muss wir
hinnehmen das muss man hinnehmen weil
die Dinge geregelt werden müssen und die
Arbeitnehmerseite hat nun wirklich nicht
das Übergewicht in Deutschland also nun
wirklich nicht aber bei der Bahn ist
das Bür bin dafür bin dafür sehr viele
Missstände zu beseinigen bin dafür wir
investieren in die Bahn wir werden ja
wahrscheinlich nachher streiten über die
Schuldenbremse wir das können wir alles
tun aber die Arbeitnehmerrechte
einzuschränken dafür gibt's überhaupt
keinen Grund und das find ich sehr sehr
wenig sehr wenig zu sagen Schlichtung
auch die auch im Sommer ist es im
Endeffekt auf eine Schlichtung
hinausgelaufen und die wurde dann auch
akzeptiert das hätte man ja haben können
ohne die
warnstre haben wir den dritten und jetzt
tatsächlich ein regulären Streik nach
Urabstimmung und der kann theoretisch
unbefristet fortgesetzt werden das ist
finde ich alles nicht zeitgemäß das ist
für die wo man sagt wir wollen weg mehr
von vom Auto und hin auf die Schiene so
das ist das ist das eine dann haben wir
sehr viele Traktoren gerade auf der
Straße also man ist gerade angewiesen
auf die Bahn diskutieren sie sowas dann
auch Herr ler auch in sie kriegen das ja
auch mit sie leben ja sehr wohl in in
dieser deutschen Wirklichkeit haben auf
der einen Seite das Recht das zu tun was
sie tun aber die Konsequenz daraus ist
natürlich genau das absolut also wir
demonstrieren dass was anderes wie
streiken streiken ist Arbeitgeber
Arbeitnehmer wir unsere Demonstration
sind da jetzt an eine politische
Entscheidung gebunden das ist jetzt
nicht das das groß verhandeln konnten
das war eine Sache die aus der
Entscheidung herausentstanden ist und
haben natürlich auch zur Kenntnis
genommen dass auch die GDL mit dazu
kommt jetzt und das ganze natürlich noch
ja für den Bürger noch anstrengender
wird und
natürlich tut leid das ist richtig nicht
aber ist nicht verhandelbar dass wir
jetzt sagen gut dann hören wir jetzt auf
und kommen in zwei Wochen wieder oder so
das geht eben leider auch nicht das ist
ehrlich gesagt gerade ein bisschen
symptomatisch für das was gerade im Land
los ist auch auch diese Runde hier man
merkt auf Kessel her was was ist denn da
im Hintergrund tatsächlich gelaufen was
passiert denn da also zum ein den
spartengewerkchaft muss man sagen als
dieses Gesetz gemacht worden ist haben
wir wieder das Problem mit handwerklich
schlechten Gesetzen ja bis heute ist
juristisch eigentlich nicht geklärt was
das bedeutet also bis heute liegen die
ganzen juristischen Fragen was bedeutet
dieses dieses tarifeinheitsgesetz was
bedeutet das wirklich wie wird gezählt
und sowas das ist alles noch nicht
geklärt nach ich weiß nicht 7 Jahren
oder sowas ja und das schafft für alle
beteiligt noch eine große Unsicherheit
das muss man das also erstmal sagen also
dann sind wir wieder bei so einem
handwerklichen Thema ohne dass ich jetzt
in die große Frage Tarifverträge da und
Streikrecht einsteigen will ich glaube
bei der Bahn haben wir noch eine
Besonderheit wir haben zum einen eine
Spartengewerkschaft aber wir haben eine
Besonderheit dass diese beiden
Gewerkschaften sich also schon massiv
befäden und das im Prinzip das DB
Management
und eben auch sehr stark die SPD
Fraktion auf der Seite von einem der
beiden steht ähm also in der Fraktion
sind ja etliche EVG Vertreter mit drin
das ist die große Gewerkschaft ja das
ist die große Gewerkschaft und
Mehrheitsprinzip in der
Demokratie und aber aber eben auch der
der DB Vorstand
stützt sich politisch sehr stark auf die
EVG kann damit sehr viele Dinge
durchsetzen und man hat ja quasi auch
den Streik der EVG unterstützt als die
EVG gestreikt hat hatte die B von sich
aus dem Betrieb eingestellt ja mit der
fol
streikasse wird geschont und sowas für
die EVG also da gab es schon so eine
stillschweigende Sympathie dafür wer ist
mann das DB Management das DB Management
hat den Betrieb eingestellt von sich aus
die EVG hat ist schon klar aber aber
stützen sich sozusagen auf wie soll man
sagen auf politischer Seite auf wen wo
wo ist da die direkte Linie also der der
Chef der EVG derr bckard kann man als
Namen nennen der ja auch für die SPD
Bundestag sitzt rümt sich ja auch mit
seinem direkten drah ins Kanzleramt ähm
er sitzt im Aufsichtsrat er gehört uns
zu denen die die Boni mitbeschlossen
haben ähm und äh er entscheidet eben
auch darüber wer in den Vorstand der DB
kommt maßgeblich mit also da muss man e
sehen da gibt es schon eine ganze Reihe
von Bezügen die eben dazu führen dass
also auch das DB Management es sich
eigentlich nicht verderben möchte mit
der EVG und deswegen geht es also auch
darum dass man sagt man versucht zu
verhindern dass die GDL erfolgreich ist
es geht nicht nur um die kleine
Gewerkschaft genau die jetzt streigt die
GDL die jetzt streigt es geht es also
nicht nur um ein paar hundert Millionen
sondern es geht auch um ein Machtkampf
zwischen zwei Gewerkschaften und in den
letzten Jahren hat also die GDL für ihre
Mitglieder also doch deutliche
Verbesserungen auch
rausgeholt dadurch Mitglieder gewonnen
und diesen Trend möchte eigentlich die
EVG natürlich verhindern das ist
legitim aber aber sozusagen auch die DB
steht eben dabei und die DB möchte
eigentlich auch ähm der GDL keinen
Erfolg gönnen und deswegen W jetzt
ernsthaft so auf dem Niveau läuft das äh
also ich meine sowas ist natürlich nie
im Detail aber aber sie sie Kön das das
auf dem Rücken der von Millionen von
Kunden natürlich also wenn sie sich mal
angucken ich meine zwischendurch hat ja
auch das DB Management sozusagen die
Verhandlung abgebrochen ich glaube das
ist ein sehr bemerkenswerter Fall dass
das DB das sozusagen der Arbeitgeber
sagt er verhandelt nicht weiter er hat
ja auch kein wirkliches wirtschaftliches
Risiko weil sie verschwinden ja nicht
vom Markt das ist e deswegen tatsächlich
es geht auf die Bürger die so oder so
dafür zahlen und und also ich glau und
und man kann eben schon sehen also das
Verhältnis ist einigermaßen
zerrüttet sie hatten ja eben den Herr
weselski sehr kritisiert aber muss eben
sagen die DB hat ja eine gewaltige
Lobbying und Medienmaschine die sie
kommandiert und mit der also wirklich
auch aus dem Hinterhalt immer aufelski
geschossen wird und also das was da wen
wen hat die da also hunderte von Leuten
gucken sich das Hochhaus in Berlin an da
sitzen Lobbyisten und Leute die die
Medien
beeinflussen bei koalitionsverhandlung
hat sich glaube ich sogar Herr Scholz
darüber beklagt über das intensive
Lobbying der Bahn dass die Verhandler
eben nicht auf Toilette gehen konnten
ohne dass da irgendein lobbyister Bahn
dran hing
das einheitsgesetz kam
damalslich in der Pharmaindustrie und in
ganz vielen Dingen ich find das
bemerkenswert dass wir das so
aus das Erstaunen ist es gibt in so
vielen Bereich wo es keinen Menschen
stört aber ist das gut so natürlich ist
das nicht gut so ich habe ja selber
gesagt ich finde die Streitigkeiten
zwischenengewerkchaften nicht gut aber
auch dass das so aber d das
Mehrheitsprinzip gilt das finde ich
schon eine richtige Sache das haben wir
in Demokratie fast immer dass die
Mehrheit und das also nicht kleine
spartener es gibt sogar
arbeitgebergewerkschaften gelbe
Gewerkschaften die scheingewerkchaften
sind das ist doch nicht das was her böt
gerade sagtib den zuständ es ging um das
Lobby generell jetzt nicht nur ich bin
keinon ich kritis das unabhäig W und
aber sozusagen also das Lobbying der DB
hat also schon einen besonderen Ruf also
gilt als besonders intensiv agressiv so
und und umgekehrt ist das kurz
nachfragen an dem Punkt der bötker das
ist ja dann so wie das klingt ist auch
keine
Einbahnstraße das heißt genau geht in
die eine Richtung und wenn du dann aus
der Politik raus bist führt der Weg
direkt in den Aufsichtsrat
m das ja in Aufsichtsrat der
aufs aber die DB hat in den letzten
jahutobilindustrie hat hat wieder ihre f
Aktivitten eben intensiviert eben auch
versorgungsbedürftige Politiker
einzustellen also von verschiedenen
Parteien Beispiel können Sie es mal
konkret machen bitte ich ich mag da
jetzt gar keine Namen nennen aber es
gibt eben Leute die wegen Burnout von
Amt zurücktreten und dann
also unmittelbar in Dienste der DB
treten ernsthaft jetzt und es gab die DB
ist da nicht wählerisch bei den Parteien
die die weiß dass sie in den nächsten
Jahren Geld von der Regierung braucht
und äh sie nimmt Leute von allen
Parteien ich weiß nicht von AFD glaube
ich nicht Linkspartei kenne ich auch
kein stimmt das her wegen her Stegner
ist das so dass es Kollegen gibt die aus
dem Bundestag ausscheiden und in der
Industrie tätig werden teilweise mehr
als gut ist das kritisiere ich das wä
übrigens glaube ich wenn man mal genauer
hingucken würde wie verbreitet das ist
dann glaube ich würde sich nicht die
Hauptaugenmerk auf die SPD richten und
das auch mal deutlich zu sagen also das
muss man schon sagen wenn sie sich die
Automobilindustrie die farmerindustrie
viele anderen angucken
ich finde das Fal nicht
besser nein ich sag ich finde das falsch
ich habe da persönlich Null Sympathie
dafür ich hab keine nebeneinkünft ja was
heißt warum ändern sie es
nicht dass Menschen in der Lage sind
solche Jobs anzunehmen wollen sie das
verbieten wie wollen Sie das verbieten
wir haben vorgeschlagen strengere
Regelungen einzuführen was
Abstandsregelung ang Geld das sind
Vorschläge die kommen eher von der SPD
aber kennen sie Leute aus ihrer Partei
aus der SPD die genau diesen Wechsel
gemacht haben ich kenne Leute aus allen
Parteien die solche wkstel machen ich
habe dafür keine Sympathie ja ich hab
keine Nebeneinkünfte ich finde das nicht
richtig Sie persönlich ich finde als
Politiker ich muss ehrlichag als
Politiker hat man Einkünfte genug D man
wird anständig bezahlt und hat es finde
ich nicht nötig und es tut auch der
Politik nicht gut es s eine kleine
Minderheit über die wir reden wenn ich
das auch noch mal sagen darf die Politik
ist es wirklich nicht ein Großteil der
abgeordnen Kollegen hat wieder
Nebeneinkünfte noch haben die lukrative
Jobs danach und wenn s im Bundestag
Ausscheiden stellen sich teilweise sogar
schlechter als davor das gibt es alles
auch also hier wir sollen bitte nicht
das Klischee über aber J also der Punkt
ist ja es geht ja gar nicht ums Geld in
erster Linie der Punkt ist doch das wird
dann strukturell irgendwann zum Problem
wie wir gerade g haben also ich finde
bei der Bahn ist es ziemlich
offensichtlich dass die Aufsicht nicht
besonders gut ist und beim
Management sie ist unterfinanziert über
lange Zeit gewesen e zu wenig investiert
aber es ist eben tatsächlich auch gerade
es ist halt eine hundertprozentiges
Staatsunternehmen und und das merkt man
halt dass die Politik da eben die
entscheidende Rolle spielt also wenn man
jetzt sagt eben die die Angestellten bei
der Bahn die kriegen den ganzen Frust ab
der Leute ich meine auch das
Zugbegleiter oder eben auch
Lockführer wichtigen Job machen auch
einen anstrengenden Job machen und zur
Zeit sehr gefrustet sind weil sie eben
sich ständig entschuldigen müssen für
etwas für dass sie überhaupt nichts
können sie machen meistens den noch sehr
gut und engagiert erlebe ich das
enth und deswegen ist glaube ich schon
dringend nötig dass eigentlich auch
offen gelegt wird und möglichst versucht
wird eine gewisse Entfernung der Politik
aus diesem Unternehmen darf ich noch mal
fragen die Tatsache we es jetzt auch
schon mehrfach gefallen ist diese Boni
die da bezahlt worden sind unvchämthit
gewesen nein das isters wo anders STT es
doch nach Leistung und hier ging es
tatsächlich darum wir haben Rekord
verpätungen wir haben rekordverspätungen
und die Bürger ärgerten sich die ganzes
Jahr über und der das Kriterium war
viele also dass der der Bahnchef viele
Stellen mit Frauen besetzt hat das war
das Kriterium zum Zahlen der Bon was er
sozusagen völlig einfach machen kann
weil das ist keine gr große Kunst und
das ist einfach was was die Bürger
natürlich
aufregt passt sozusagen nicht zu einem
Leistung wenn ein Automobilkonzern hohe
Bonis auszahlen kann dann hängt es in
der Regel daran dass das dass das die
Leistung entsprechend war was man das
sehen kann in der Regel am Aktienkurs
und es sind die Aktionäre die das
Bezahlen hier ist es so der Bürger
bezahlt für etwas und kriegst aber keine
gute
leistungf was haben den Leute z
und haben
sichilenrie also immer nur die
Staatsunternehmen zuen bei aller Kritik
muss ich ih ganz ehrlich sagen das ist
wirklich komplett daneben wir haben
teilweise Bereiche wo es Unternehmen
gibt die Gesetzentwürfe schreiben und um
das zu bekommen was sie sich wünschen
als Lobby wir haben ein Lobbyismus der
ist auf einer anderen Seite des
politischen Spektrums zu Hause so zu tun
nein es ist alles schlecht aber ich w
mich dagegen zu
tun n wirklich D das sehr an die Grenz
il die wir reden heute über die Bahn
gerne einmal Herrn btker Fragen noch mal
wer befindet darüber und warum nach
welchen Kriterien kriegt der Vorstand
der Bahn bei dem Zustand in dem die Bahn
ist und bei diesen armen Angestellten
die ständig erklären müssen warum der
Zug nach buxte Hude jetzt doch wieder
nicht fährt warum gibt es diese bon
nicht was ist das für ein System
strukturell was steckt dahinter also es
ist ja üblich dass sozusagen Manager
Boni bekommen mit denen eben auch die
Leistung belohnt wird es gibt immer
immer einen persönlichen Teil und einen
Teil der am Unternehmenserfolg hängt und
diese Werte die jetzt genannt wurden das
war also der Unternehmenserfolg und
worin besteht der unternehm Erfolg der
Deutschen Bahn und da gab es sozusagen
Pünktlichkeit und Kundenzufriedenheit
die wurden jeweils nicht erreicht dafür
haben also die die Manager also auch auf
den Ebenen unterhalb des Vorstandes
haben dafür keine Boni bekommen sie
haben aber Boni bekommen für die
Erreichung der Ziele
Mitarbeiterzufriedenheit und
Frauenförderung und die wurden wohl auch
noch im Laufe des Jahres noch mal etwas
angehoben aber da sind Details nicht
bekannt sodass die D also schon auf
ordentliche Boni gekommen sind und
dieses
Mitarbeiterzufriedenheit bitte warum
sind die Mitarbeiter der Bahn so
zufrieden na ja ich glaube man hat
sozusagen gesagt wenn sich die
Mitarbeiter Zufriedenheit nicht
verschlechtert gibt es bereits den Bonus
also es wurde nicht mal eine
Verbesserung verlangt sondern nur der
kann sich ja K
verschlechternchuldig so aber aber das
hat ich meine das muss aber sagen
niemand von uns also wenn hier ein
Bündel Geldscheine auf dem Boden liegen
würde würde sich jeder von uns danach
Bücken also insofern ich kann eigentlich
am Vorstand keinen Vorwurf machen dass
er also dann
sozusagen so ein Bonus annimmt aber aber
wer befindet darüber das ist der
Aufsichtsrat und das ist sozusagen der
Punkt der kam die Politik dann so das
ist die Verbindung in die Poli genau im
Aufsichtsrat sitzen also drin eben
Vertreter der Ministerien meistens die
Staatssekretäre es sitzen drin Vertreter
des
Bundestages und es gibt noch ein paar
unabhängige dabei wobei wir in den
letzten Jahren also eine Verschiebung
hatten dass die unabhängigen also
Wirtschaftsvertreter mehr W rausgegangen
sind und durch Abgeordnete ersetzt
wurden was was was verdient man da im
Aufsichtsrat das ist nicht dramatisch 20
000 € ich glaube als Abgeordneter oder
als als Staatssekretär muss man glaube
ich abführen bei abgeordnen bin ich mir
nicht ganz sicher also das ist keine
Sache des Geldes aber das sind alles
Leute die das als Nebenjob machen
durchschnittlich bleiben sie zweieinhalb
Jahre im Aufsichtsrat über die letzten
10 Jahre ja das heißt ich sehe da schon
auch ein massives kompetenzproblem und
die verhandeln eben mit Vorständen die
also einen riesigen Stab haben der ihn
unterstützt und ich glaube also wir
haben da sozusagen
eine eine Macht in Balance zu Lasten
eben der Aufsichtsräte und was dazu
führt dass eben die DB nicht vernünftig
gesteuert wird okay und wäre das nicht
eine Sache jetzt mal ganz platt gefackt
für Profis ja natürlich genau das ist es
ja eben also eigentlich müssten im
Aufsichtsrat die besten Leute sitzen und
das ist auch für ein Unternehmenserfolg
ungemein wichtig also die Vorstände die
sind die die man dann kennt aber die im
Hintergrund eigentlich eine Unternehmen
steuern das ist auch in der
Privatwirtschaft so und das ist eben in
der Bahn da muss man doch einfach sehen
dass das über Jahrzehnte sich nicht gut
entwickelt hat lass mal was zu den
Profis sagen wenn sie sich angucken dass
eine Bahn dass eine bankpite geht die
der Staat rettet eine Bank wo nur Leute
im Aufsichtsrat sitzen die alles Profis
sind Wirtschaftsprüfer
Wirtschaftskapitäne nichts bemerkt geh
nach Hause mit den größten bon das
findet kein Mensch skandalös im
Gegenteil das st ich höre das jedenfalls
nicht ich find das alles nicht gut
worüber wir reden mus deutlich zu sagen
nur so zu tun sei die Grenze da wo es
ein Staatsunternehmen gibt und da
skandalisere ich das mehr als anders
woo der Finanzkrise haben wir uns doch
alle aufg über
Banken es GI doch viele Unternehmen die
hervorragend
kontrolliert übrigens normalerweise auch
gewerkschaftter drin was überhaupt nicht
zu kritisieren ist und eben ansonsten
Profis aber hier mit dem mit der Politik
das läuft bei der Bahn tatsächlich nicht
besonders sieht man am vololg ich ich
fand interessant in einem Interview Herr
bötker von ihnen habe ich seinen
Gedanken gefunden den ich den man gar
nicht zu denken wagt eigentlich nich der
Gedanke diese vermeintlich kaputt
gesparte Bahn hat in Wahrheit gar kein
Geldproblem sagen
sie ja ich ich weiß nicht wie wieder der
Kontext ist genau war also also momentan
ist es so wen sie sagen die die geben
skandalös viel Steuergeld aus ja weil
sie es irgendwie auch haben ja und das
passt halt so überhaupt nicht zu dem was
man öffentlich immer wieder hört wir
brauchen Milliarden um Schienennetz und
Infrastruktur und so weiter und da geht
sozusagen wirklich ans Eingemachte und
und wir sind kaputt gespart worden also
diese beiden Gedanken passen tut mir
leid nicht zusammen ja also ich glaube
dies kaputt gespart ist eben nicht ganz
falsch also gerade wenn sich den neuen
Ausbau von Strecken angucken der ist vor
20 Jahren massiv gekürzt worden das
waren mal 4 Milliarden vor 20 Jahren
dann hat man das auf 1,5 Milliarden
gemacht und über alle Regierung ich
möchte jetzt nicht irgendeine Partei
benennen da waren wirklich alle Parteien
beteiligt hat sich das dann auf 1,5
Milliarden eingependelt von
Inflationsausgleich gar nicht zu reden
so in dem Sinne kann man sagen man hat
das Netz nicht weiter in entwickelt für
die Ansprüche und wie gesagt man hat es
vernachlässigt parteiübergreifend und
insofern stimmt es also auch kaputt
gespart momentan wird mehr Geld zur
Verfügung gestellt
m und momentan hat die Bahn also nicht
primär ein Geldproblem also das Geld ist
da das muss man sagen da hat die
Bundesregierung jetzt einiges getan und
also auch anlässlich der aktuellen Krise
haben da alle Parteien sich darauf
verständigt zu sagen das versprochene
Geld für die Bahn wird bereitgestellt ja
so aber
ähm wir haben eben ein Problem wir haben
kaum die Ressourcen um das zu verbauen
ich glaube in den nächsten Jahren die
Bahn wird Probleme haben das Geld
auszugeben es gibt eben auch jede Menge
Verschwendung das kommt noch mit hinzu
wir haben einen viel zu großen
Wasserkopf der also auch immer weiter
wächst und immer größer wird bei der
btie so viel Bürokratie und das ist ja
eben auch die Klage von vielen dass man
sagt es wird immer mehr Entscheidung
auch
zentralisiert die Leute vor Ort die Bahn
Sachverstand haben dürfen immer weniger
entscheiden
das heißt also wir haben in der Tat
schon auch ein managementprem aber aber
wenn man mal die große Linie sich eben
anschaut muss man sagen es ist zu wenig
investiert worden und jetzt müssen wir
auch darüber nachdenken wie kommen wir
an die Ressourcen ran also wo sollen die
Planer herkommen die Bauingenieure und
die Bauleute die in nächsten Jahren die
Strecke bauen so und in dem Zusammenhang
sie erinnern sich an unser Gespräch dass
wir hier mal hatten da ging es um die
Strecke Hamburg Hanover ne han ja und
die muss dann wo vorbeiführen wo ja es
gibt also eine bestandsstrecke die ja
heute da ist die führt über Lüneburg und
Zelle so und ähm und seit vielen Jahren
die steht seit 20 Jahren eigentlich in
allen Planungen drin es geht um eine
Neubaustrecke wo man vor allem mehr
Kapazität braucht auch für den
Güterverkehr ja der Hamburger Hafen
wächst ähm die Dänen bauen für viel Geld
also die femannbeltquerung um also auch
mehr Verkehr auf der Schiene nach
Mitteleuropa reinzbringen ähm und seit
Jahren wird also um die Trasse eben
gestritten und da gab es jetzt eben das
war letztes Jahr auch das Thema seiner
Zeit ähm dass also äh es massiven
Widerstand gibt gegen eine Neubaustrecke
die Idee ist dass man eine neubarstrecke
baut in lang der Autobahn mit relativ
wenig Eingriffen in die Landschaft und
ohne zusätzliche Belastung bei diesen
bestehenden Strecken die ja durch große
stäte durchführen ähm und dass es dort
eben massiven Widerstand gibt eben vor
allem von der SPD und das gipfelte jetzt
also in einem Parteitagsbeschluss der
also eigentlich sagt das gesamte Konzept
zum Ausbau der Schiene soll gestoppt
werden und wir wollen keine
hochgeschwindigkeitsneubarstrecken haben
und das will die SPD nicht bitte was das
will die SPD nicht das ist eine
Beschluss beim SPD Parteitag gewesen der
also aus meiner Sicht wenn wenn der
tatsächlich zu politischen Handlung
führt der eigentlich das Wachstum auf
der Schiene in Norddeutschland quasi
unmöglich macht also dann können sie
sagen alle verlagerungsziele oder so sag
nicht in Norddeutschland das wäre also
ein verheerender Rückschlag für die
China ver stin warum will die SPD keine
Ausbau der Bahnstrecke ich bin kein
Bahnexperte ich habe die mehr mehrheits
Mehrheitsmeinung dazkennnis genommen die
hen glaube ich sehr stark damit zusammen
dass ja heute baufahen ohnehin schwierig
ist und wenn sie die Bevölkerung nicht
mitgenommen kriegen dann dauern die
Dinge ewig lang wir brauchen in
Deutschland ohnehin viel zu lange wir
müssen was tun investieren in den ÖPNV
und insofern ist die abwegung in
ländernern wie Nord Westfalen oder
Niedersachsen das waren die Kollegen die
da mehrheitlich für gestimmt haben die
aus diesen Landesverbänden kommen die
gesagt haben wir wollen lieber in den
bestehenden auf den bestehenden Strecken
das ausbauen da kriegt man die
Bevölkerung eher mit wir haben in
Deutschland kein System wie in China wo
sie einfach mal eben im Dorf wegwalzen
wenn Sie eine Klinik bauen oder wenn Sie
eine Zugstrecke bauen so läuft das bei
uns ja richtigerweise nicht sonder die
Bevölkerung hat da ihre
Einspruchsmöglichkeiten die werden auch
genutzt ich respektiere diese
Mehrheitsmeinung ich muss sagen ich bin
davon persönlich nicht betroffen ich
wohne nicht in der Region bei mir ist
das nicht so dass das ein Problem wä so
ist das so aber so ist das mit mehr der
Demokratie auch in allen Parteien auch
das ist nicht nur in der SPD so dass
wenn sie über solche Dinge abstimmen die
Leute sozusagen das Sein bestimmt das
Bewusstsein dass was die Bevölkerung
Ihnen in Ihrer Region sagt halt auch
mitnehmen und das ist ein Teil dessen
dass sie als Fachmann sagen ich wünsche
mir das auf dem Reisbrett anders
verstehe ich aber Demokratie ist eben
manchmal nicht einfach so dass man das
mach aber Herr Stegner was ist denn denn
mit dem deutschlandtempo also nicht nur
auf die Bahn bezogen wir haben also
deutschlandempo gibt's bislang herr
Scholz hatte das ja als großes Ziel
angekündigt das einzige Beispiel wo das
geklappt hat sind bisher die LNG
Terminals als große Großprojekt das ist
jetzt nur auch nicht so schwierig auf
die Beine zu stellen aber es gelang eben
in rekordzuständ na ja von der Technik
die da nötig ist wenn ich mal Vergleiche
mit Stuttgart 21 mit dem Bahnhof
beispielsweise oder mit dem BR oder so
also es gibt ja Großprojekte und das
hier das ging aber was man gemacht hat
ist sämtliche Umwelt und sonst Auflagen
einfach beiseite gewischt und gesagt wir
müssen das weil es vom National
Interesse ist und ich finde so kann man
bei z.B bei der Bahn wenn es darum geht
dass wir endlich also ich meine wir sind
so weit nicht nur ich war jetzt gerade
mal in Japan ich meine da ist die Bahn
ist ein vollkommen andere Dimension was
Geschwindigkeit angeht die haben ihr
eigenes
Schnellbahnnetz das ist man in 500 km in
unter vi unter 3 Stunden also das ist
alles es klappt auf die Minute es ist
alles wunderbar und selbst genau also
wir immer sagen irgendwie das ist weit
weg Japan ist vielleicht auch so ein
bisschen äh mythisch aber eben
es ist auch in Frankreich so es ist in
Italien so es ist in Österreich so in
der Schweiz also es geht und was wir uns
hier leisten ist dass wir eben immer
diese Befindlichkeiten hier war glaube
ich spdchef klinkball der seiner
Wahlkreis versprochen hat das kommt hier
nicht und ähnlich war es als die Strecke
die die
Schnellstrecke Berlin München dass dann
eben auch Politiker gesagt haben aber
meine Stadt hier die soll da auch noch
angeschlossen werden deswegen gibt's
mehr stops als eigentlich nötig wären
das ist alles nicht zeitgemäß so darf
man mit sowas nicht umgehen es geht um
Großprojekte die für unsere stand für
unseren Standort enorm wichtig sind und
wenn hier eben die Frage ist ob der äh
ob der Hafen in Hamburg weiter wachsen
kann und das eben für den Gütertransport
nötig ist dann frage ich mich wollen wir
das alles auf die Straße packen also ich
meine das ist doch nicht zukunftsfähig
wir müssen noch die die
ja aber aber das ist so wir müssen die
Bürger mitnehmen dann klappt das alles
nicht dann klappen aber auch die Wind
vor wie sie das Mö ich finde viele von
diesen von diesen Maßnahmen muss man
einfach mit einer Priorität ja aber so
ist es doch also ich meine wir können
doch nicht sagen
Windkraft Anlage dauert hier zu lange 5
Jahre meinen sie dass wir uns das
leisten können wollen wir dahin wir die
gastkrawerke die gebaut werden mü
50 Stück kein einziges geplant immer man
kann le man kann leicht so reden
natürlich müssen wir das ändern wir
müssen Verwaltungsstrukturen abbauen und
Bürokratie aber unbedingt aber wir
müssen zur Kenntnis nehmen dass wir
trotzdem demokratische Entscheidungen
haben und es nicht so einfach ist so
eben mal zu sagen ich ma das halt und am
Ende entscheiden die Bürger üs auch wen
sie wählen auch das ist der Demokratie
ja aber vielleicht wählen Sie gerade
weil sie so frustriert das weiß ich mag
ja bei ihnen so sein aber ich will schon
sagen man kann das alles leicht sagen
aber
tun sind sie do auch glücklich oder
ich will ih mal sagen bei den LNG
Terminals hatten wir eine Notlage durch
den Krieg und da war die Lage so dass
gesagt worden ist die Wirtschaft bricht
bei uns ein wir die kriegen die Wohnung
nicht geheizt dass da die Regierung W
ich ohne dass sie dafür besonders viel
Lob bekommen hätte das sehr ordentlich
geregelt dass wir vernünftig D
dururchgekommen
sind aber das was da passiert aber das
was da passiert ist ja auch Standort
gefährdend ganz ehrlich ja ja ich bin
auch dafür das zu ändern ich sage nur
man darf sich nicht so einfach machen zu
sagen das sind jetzt ein paar SPD
Politiker oder sowas sondern es ist in
demokratischen Parteien so die Leute
entscheiden mit Mehrheit aber gib auch
und die Entscheidung kann man gut oder
schlecht finden das geht in den anderen
Parteien auch aber es bleibt
demokratisch da geht nicht einer von wir
machen das undemokratisch denänemark hat
das Verfahren und so haben die ihre
genehmigungs und Planungsverfahren
beschleunigt dass man am
Anfang einlegen kann und dann nicht mehr
und dann läuft das Ding und bei uns bei
jedem Planungsschritt wieder aber müssen
wir es doch mal machen wir reden mal
bürokratieald es irgendwie hier konkr
ich würde l mal sagen also was mich
besonders aber erschüttert also Herr
stenerich völlig recht das ist jetzt
nicht einmalig das hängt noch nicht an
der SPD ich könnte ihn Projekte nennen
in ganz Deutschland eisenbahnprojekte wo
also Politiker aller Parteien irgendwo
gedreht haben dass dann Tunnel gebaut
wurde der ökonomisch wahnsinnig ist oder
sowas das ist keineswg spezifisch will
ich auch nicht
behaupten das neue für mich sozusagen
und das Schlimme an diesem
parteisbeschluss ist für mich
normalerweise sehen die Politiker immer
zu dass man ihre Fingerabdrücke da nicht
erkennt also bei vielen Projekten wissen
sie gar nicht wenn sie nicht wirklich
Experte sind welcher Politiker da im
Hintergrund ein bisschen geschupst hat
die schubsen alle ein bisschen wirklich
alle Parteien also wirklich nicht dass
ich da falschen Eindruck der verstorben
Herr schuble hat gut geschubst da im
Hintergrund gut jetzt nennen sie dann
einen Namen aber wie man kann wirklich
von allen Parteien die Namen könnte man
die Namen nennen aber stimmt hier ist es
jetzt so dass man sagt wir machen
sozusagen dieses Prinzip dass sagen
bitte nicht bei uns sozusagen das ist
bet teilagsbeschluss das ist das was
also einmalig was ich einmalig und
ärgerlich finde
und und ich glaube wir müssen nachdenken
und ich meine Politiker aller Parteien
beim deutschlandtempo sind wir wieder
die sagen im Prinzip wir machen was aber
ich sehe ja nicht mal Vorarbeiten ich
sehe jetzt nicht dass es irgendeine
Kommission gibt dass Gutachten vergeben
werden dass man sagt wie machen wir denn
das wirklich ja sondern ich meine ich
ich sehe dass alle Politiker sagen ja ja
das müsste vereinfacht werden aber
tatsächlich die Umsetzung wden äh eben
auch gesprochen das betrifft die
Landwirtschaft eben auch wenn man sagt
sie brauchen LTE oder sowas ja das also
ähm ich sehe nicht dass sozusagen diese
Wörter wirklich mit Taten gefüllt werden
also auch jetzt
entscheidungsvorbereiten und das ist
halt ist ja dann nicht undemokratisch
sondern im Zweifel einfach geht's um es
geht um politische Führung